what's your thought on this well look we
look at a lot of data the chair Yellen
and all Federal Reserve officials keep
emphasizing that we're data dependent
and every day more data comes in we're
paying attention to markets and the good
news is in Minneapolis and in all of the
bank's we've got very strong teams of
economists that are chewing on this and
we put it all together and you know
we'll wait and see so data dependent
once again we've heard everything you've
always you've always been dated depicted
so I mean like that's it I'm giving that
a no well you could try again but you're
making some nuisance in other places
recently you gave a talk at Brookings
Institution yesterday and talking about
too big to fail and suggesting that the
least you're part of the Fed needs to
take a look at whether it has to be more
regulation dodd-frank didn't go far
enough tell us what drove you to this
yeah so look we all remember the crisis
2007-2008 I was in the middle of it
running the tarp program we hated that
we hated that we had to bail out the
banks and I think Americans across the
political spectrum hated that as well we
see the anger and the American people
still today none of us wants to be in
that situation again so dodd-frank was
passed very quickly because they wanted
to reform the financial system which I
supported but the more transformational
measures were taken off the table things
like like breaking up the banks or
putting so much capital in the big banks
that you turn them into utilities so
they virtually can't fail there are a
number of other options well here we are
six or seven years later and in my view
we've done some good the banks are safer
they do have more capital they've got
deeper liquidity but we have not taken
the risk of a bailout off the table if a
number of banks ran into trouble at the
same time I think policymakers today
would be forced to bail them out but
you're never going to take risk out of
the system maybe you take it out of
banks hands but somebody is going to be
left holding the bag and it's those
investors who have risky assets and it's
insurance companies that's 401 K so it's
not like it's evaporating it's just
going to someone else I agree but it
needs to be distributed in a way that
it's safe so in the late 1980s a
thousand little savings and loans failed
in the S&L crisis that was terrible for
those firms but there was no risk of an
economic collapse in the tech boom in
the late 1990s we then had the crash
devastating for Silicon Valley but once
again no risk of an economic collapse
that's what we need to be I think the
concern is that
banks are still too big to fail in fact
a lot of people say to bigger to fail
now right after we injected 13 trillion
dollars into the financial system to
save bank's total assets of the 6
biggest have climbed to about 10
trillion dollars check this out a custom
chart that Hillary made for me you can
see that we were only at about eight
trillion before the financial crisis and
and only about nine when we came out so
they continue to get bigger and bigger I
will say that this is different for
different banks so JP Morgan bank
america and wells fargo are the ones
that really have grown goldman sachs
morgan stanley and city have actually
got a little sauce and you know this is
a fascinating chart but i wonder if it
asks the right question if you compare
the size of US banks to the size of gdp
in the united states as opposed to other
countries actually our banks are
relatively smaller than other banks
that's correct so this is not just an
American problem this is true all around
the world and we can't you know in the
u.s. we can't control what other people
do in other countries what I'm saying is
we need to be honest with the American
people about the risks that still exists
in our financial system take action to
make our banking system safer and then
hopefully we can encourage other
countries to follow along but there's
less risk than there was do you agree
with that I do agree with that but the
question is this I don't want the
American people to think that we have
solved too big to fail when I believe in
my heart we have not solved it yet and
that's why I'm standing up and speaking
forward because if I were standing up I
wouldn't be doing my job I guess what I
want to understand though it was the
Treasury Department Hank Paulson's
Treasury Department that during the
crisis push these takeovers wamu Bear
Stearns those are the contributors to
making these banks even bigger today
that's absolutely true and I was in the
middle of that so I'm not absolving
myself of responsibility I take
responsibility for that in the midst of
that terrible crisis we had to make the
problem worse by encouraging these
mergers just to stabilize the system we
knew at the time hey if we can stabilize
the system that's going to be a
short-term victory we're still going to
need to deal with too big to fail
long-term I just don't want to have the
future Treasury secretary the future Fed
chair 20 years from now or 50 years from
now back in the situation we were in
having to make those terrible choices
then is it fair that the populace
opinion is
still so anti banks and banks continue
to pay fine after fine tied to acquiring
these other banks when it was the
Treasury Department that pushed you to
do it look I understand those concerns
and those are very fair but I also
understand the concerns on Main Street
right the main street was devastated by
this people it's not just people who
bought homes and bought mortgages maybe
they couldn't afford when this
manifested itself into a deep recession
a great recession people lost their jobs
and that wasn't fair and so there's a
lot of anger in the country which I am a
double zero interest rates has hurt Main
Street zero interest rate has helped
banks and hedge funds and money managers
asset holders as their assets have risen
over the last five years and mom and
pops on the street haven't gotten their
wages up Obamacare has made it difficult
for them to hire more people into small
businesses I I agree that asset
valuations have been helping the wealthy
more than they've been helping
middle-class and lower-income agree a
hundred percent and that's what's so
tough about coming out of this terrible
crisis you you all know the Rogoff and
Reinhart book about this time is
different and how hard it is to recover
from these banking crises that's exactly
why we don't want this to happen again
because it ends up not just being Wall
Street who's heard it ends up being Main
Street and they're paying for a year
after year after year so I think you're
making my point for me